[Musique]
maurice vient enfin de trouver le cadeau
qu'il veut offrir à sa dulcinée miroirs
décoratifs il le déplace pour mieux le
voir ou en tentant de remettre à sa
place tout ce qui me choque il est tout
penaud quand il voit le commerçant
s'approcher il réclame à toris le prix
du miroir et doit-il de payer
au départ le miroir est bien installé
ses choristes qui l'a déplacé même s'il
ne l'a pas fait exprès il a échappé le
miroir a donc été brisé par sa faute
comme il est responsable du bris du
miroir qui veulent payer pour garder
leur clientèle
certains commerçants acceptent d'assumer
le coût de ces incidents
mais pour lui le mot de l'histoire
si vous êtes dans un magasin d'objets
fragiles ne fait pas le défendre pour
vous payer le gros prix